[Music]
hey
[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congar galatians
[Music]
he's mixing it up he's mixing it up
isn't he he really is though that's what
they say about him they go oh is he
mixing it up and i go yup
we get it
um
i am here we got the oops merch out
there killing it got some new merch
coming out it may be out already by the
time i uh
uh
no this podcast come out i don't know if
it will be but there's new merch coming
out and also all month in the month of
may you if you if you buy something
you're entered into a raffle to win that
[ __ ] congratulations varsity jacket
which absolutely checks all boxes jesus
dude
the jacket checks all boxes doesn't it
huh
so go pick up that [ __ ] life rips
merch the oops merch
the uh you know i you know we got that
don't push me merch right
and uh but we you know so and they're
entered into it even if you get we got
those life rips tumblers
uh and you're entered just if you make a
purchase you're entered to win those
[ __ ]
uh varsity jackets and congratulations
there's only 10 of them and dude they
check all boxes come on man
what the [ __ ] are you a box checker um
we got tour dates coming up what the
[ __ ] we got crystalia coming up in
atlanta georgia september 9th washington
dc september 10th
stockton
oakland september
peoria rockford illinois in october
raleigh october 21st savannah georgia
october 22nd
denver colorado november 5th
that's at that bellco theater that's a
big one cheyenne wyoming november
boston at the wang theater
uh
get your tickets they're almost gone
there november 12th and jacksonville
florida december 3rd
crystallia.com for tickets go on over to
crystalia.com give it a they make great
you know what i mean they make a great
gift don't they make great gifts don't
gifts make great gifts i love when
people say that well they make a great
gift and it's just like anything could
be a gift right
anything's a great gift you know they
just the thing about these is they make
great gifts
so go ahead and give it as a gift buy
one for yourself pick one up for
yourself too while you're at it
um
but uh you know he really his friend
says he can't do a texan accent but he's
texting and what the [ __ ] does his
friend know his friend david sullivan
says he can't do southern accent boy oh
we but he can't can it
my buddy is so texting he tried to
[ __ ] make a
uh what do you call it he he's got a
ranch my buddies david sullivan he's in
that show on amazon i believe he's on
amazon prime whatever's [ __ ]
streaming service that nobody watches
it's on that one and he's on um and he's
on a show called the wilds or something
or the wild and it's about an island
full of chicks or some [ __ ] i have no
idea cause i don't watch it because i am
a bad friend
i'm a good friend though i'll watch it i
did watch a little bit of his parts he's
a good actor dude what can i say my
friend david sullivan he came to the
laugh actor the other night with a
[ __ ] cowboy hat on
and we're in los angeles but it's all
good
i was in texas and he says i can't do a
text in accent but boy [ __ ] that
um
you know and uh
and we did uh well i was in so i was in
texas i was in austin here's the deal
dude i know i was in austin and i know
people are like what the [ __ ] did you do
a show in austin i did i popped in dude
but it wasn't announced my buddy mike
linoche was doing a show at the vulcan
theater which by the way the vulcan
theater is a fantastic venue in austin
for comedy apparently they used to do dj
[ __ ] they used to hire djs they tried to
get skrillex to go in
and then covet happened and they
couldn't have people stack people you
know close together so they put tables
there to spread them out and they became
a comedy venue and it's really great
dude the vulcan or if you're mike
lenocchi he says vulcan like he's
[ __ ] i'm like dude it's vulcan just
say vulcan
and every time he's like the vulcan
i'm like bro
you know what it is because i'm telling
you so store that information and then
use that right
so it's at the vulcan theater and uh
it's a great venue in austin the comedy
scene in austin is great you know
i don't know what to expect you know
it's basically it's joe rogan tony
hinchcliffe and uh i think tom segura
lives there but i don't even know if he
goes up
there at all i know rogan does and
hinchcliffe does
but it's kind of becoming a scene
there's other good comedian
comedians like my buddy isan and uh
derek um
and they [ __ ] kill it dude
uh they were on the same show
uh
and uh as me as mike linocci and uh
there's a lot of cool local comics that
are up and coming
um
and i went to the uh creek in the cave
too which is like a a spot that's very
cool on a monday night and they had like
a showcase show or something that turned
into an open mic and i showed up and
they were like do you want to go up and
i went up on the end of the showcase
show
and uh you know it's really funny doing
a show
out of your element like they weren't my
fans right like because i didn't sell
tickets for this show
and um and i went and they were like do
you want to go up and i was like sure
and i was like everybody here hates me
that's my that's my thing when i told
you i've told you if you've listened to
this podcast i walk into rooms and i
think everybody hates me and it's sad
and i'm working on it with my therapist
i try to [ __ ] hope for the best but
it really is something that i struggle
with like i feel like i walk into rooms
and people don't like me for a reason or
not and it's been that way ever since i
was a [ __ ] kid
so i'm like these comics probably think
that this is their scene which it is and
i'm just coming in and
and i [ __ ] walked in with this idea
of what it might be like
and i watched some of the comics and
they were very good
and um
and then they were like do you want to
go up and i said okay and i went to the
green room and there those comics were
and uh one in particular i was like this
guy's gotta hate me you know
because he was he was funny on stage i'm
like he probably [ __ ] hates a comic
from l.a i walk in and this dude says
wow it's so weird you're in here i drink
coffee out of a life rips mug every
morning and i was like
isn't that just like life dude
and it made me feel good and it made me
you know i keep trying to [ __ ] store
this information that i get you know
like i get mad at my buddy for saying
vulcan when he should say vulcan
when he knows it's vulcan but i am
living the same way because i know that
this preconceived notion i have that
people just [ __ ] don't like me when i
walk into a room
is not true because they it's it's ego
based do you know what i mean i'm
assuming that people even would would
take a look at me and think [ __ ] that
guy like either either the either they
know who i am as a comedian and they and
i'm thinking oh they probably don't like
my comedy which is uh so insecure
but that's ego based like why do they
even know who i am or they're even
looking at me thinking anything is ego
based
like maybe i'm just a guy in a place
right and uh and i have to get over that
and so and and that was another instance
in that green room that i just have to
get over
that showed me that i just [ __ ] it's
all made up in my head
you know we live with these [ __ ]
constructs in our [ __ ] heads that are
just so idiotic man
and then we have these memories that we
build up that we color as well like
truth happens and then we color it a
different way
right oh god it's like
it's like humans we're too
[ __ ] smart for our own good and too
dumb for our own good you know
it's like that's what it is i wish we
were either just these people that they
create in movies
that are like i use 80 of my brain this
is the year 2090.
or why can't we just be a [ __ ] lizard
like really why can't we just be some
mid-brained
[ __ ]
you know oh
like i saw a documentary on a a t-rex
and he was like trying to
it's that new thing on apple tv the
prius i thought it would be good for
calvin to watch until i saw a [ __ ]
t-rex eating a bunch of turtles and i
was like oh this is too violent
these these need to be more like
cartoons for him to understand
otherwise he's just gonna this is like
dark [ __ ] that he gets you ever put on a
documentary for your kid because you
think it's like about animals and then
it's like
you know
the duckbill platypus is actually very
violent
it [ __ ] and it kills and [ __ ] its prey
and you're oh okay okay all right we'll
go back to coco melon
and um
and so we wa so i'm watching this
prehistoric thing on apple tv which is
done by written richard attenborough
of course dude you know
can there be a documentary about
something grand that richard
attenborough's not doing
like
like he i think he did i don't know if
he did planet earth or what or if even
there is he did planet earth and now
he's doing prehistoric life and it's so
funny they tried to make it a little bit
different
than planet earth but the similarities
are so striking because i get the same
guy that not only are they so striking
that now they actually show cause on
planet earth he's just like the frog is
[ __ ] licking a leaf for an hour and a
half
and the mate comes and depending on how
the frog licks the leaf the mate will
come
and look what they do they're the only
animals besides human that do oral
copulation
the frog lays on its back and spreads
open its frog [ __ ] and the other frog
eats it out
and then um
and then now it's so much like planet
earth that you could have just smelled
that
you smelled the [ __ ] executives being
like it's too much like the [ __ ]
planet earth so let's just film so they
film richard attenborough now like next
to a skeleton you know have you seen it
they film them next to it
david attenborough who's richard
attenborough oh we just thought
david attenborough
it should be richard you know
david attenborough and so david
attenborough
is it
richard attenbero is the guy in dress
are they brothers they gotta be they
sound the [ __ ] same
jurassic park whatever who cares he'll
find out but uh anyway david
attenborough so richard attenborough is
the guy in the jurassic park with the
white hat and the white suit they're
brothers and they're the white hands
right soon anytime i see a white guy
with white hat i say [ __ ] i go
dana like a piece of [ __ ] and he knows
he pretty whenever a guy wears a white
hat i go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
and so
so david attenborough is doing the thing
and they film him now because they were
like we got to film them next to a
[ __ ]
skeleton t-rex otherwise it's too much
like platinum or planet earth and they
film rich david attenborough
and and his hair's all messed up and
it's hilarious because it's like
like if you watch this thing on apple tv
the prehistoric life or whatever the
[ __ ]
you he rich david
[ __ ] whatever it is dude i'm going to
say richard or david just get on board
david attenborough is sitting there and
he's just like
the dinosaurs are you know
from a trillion years ago but what you
might not know and his hair is like got
this [ __ ] cowlick and it's it's like
you know the hair and makeup lady were
just like
should we fix it and then another person
said
he's 107.
like what for what
right
like at what age do you get to where
just it's not even like looks are not
important anymore it's just that they're
not even achievable
right like old guys just walk all
hunched over with [ __ ]
just pink splotchy skin and they just
don't give a [ __ ] but do they still get
boners
do they still want
i hope that goes away dude
i hope that goes away one time my friend
my one time my friend said do you think
that when you get to heaven and i said
i'll stop you right there i'm gonna
answer no but he said do you think when
you get to heaven like you get to have
sex with whoever you want to and i was
just like i i don't know man you know
this is just like what is his deep
thoughts by jack handy and he was like i
think in heaven they remove that sexual
urge and that you could get to just
chill and it's not straight and you're
not stressed out about it and i was like
okay and he says that dude and if i told
you i didn't think about him saying that
every three months
you will your boy will be a liar
[ __ ] i [ __ ] it up [ __ ] it doesn't
matter dude i i think about it all the
time even though there's probably no
heaven yeah worst game show hi guys
welcome to probably know heaven i'm your
host alec baldwin
um
so anyway so david attenborough does
this thing and it's it's violent as [ __ ]
and his hair is all messed up you got to
see it
and uh they make it really good though
like it's one of those series that you
watch and when you watch it you're like
oh
this is when they should make they
should have never made this until now
because they look like real [ __ ]
dinosaurs
that are doing this because the cgi is
so good so
i'm watching this t-rex swim which by
the way i didn't know about this but in
five minutes i learned david
attenborough said
the tyrannosaurus is actually
violently effective in water and i was
like oh well let's i'm in you know
already and so he's swimming with the
young
t-rexes behind him
and it's like but the tyrannosaurus
isn't the biggest [ __ ]
thing on planet earth it's another
[ __ ] thing
a whale that's [ __ ] like two times as
big as the tyrannosaurus rex and then
they show the big ass prehistoric whale
you know just lurking and it's like but
don't worry the tyrannosaurus is
effectively violent in the ocean as well
while swimming
but what he has to worry about is the
t-rex's [ __ ] young and then the t-rex
is young is like me me trying to swim
and then the big ass whale comes and
eats the thing and i'm like do i have to
turn this off but it kind of showed it
off screen like it just showed the
little blip of the t-rex the mini t-rex
just go underwater and so my son just
thought it like took an extra dip
and but i'm like i got to turn it off
because then they started eating a
turtle and [ __ ]
and my son kind of likes turtles so
anyway
i got off on a tangent because of that
but really what i was trying to say is i
was in dallas and austin and i don't
even know
why i got off on a tangent that hard
because even in the middle of the
tangent i was like i still gotta get
back to austin
and now i don't remember
but so
uh i went and i did the creek in the
cave and um
[Music]
it was nice i did a set for like 30
minutes
and it was actually really cool because
like a lot of the comics like the room
was kind of like empty-ish
and then as i was on stage i think other
comics came and started watching it
you know and it's always the comics that
watch in the back of the room
it's like there's [ __ ] seats that are
left open and the comics are all in the
back of the room just judging you know
so to get them to laugh is good even
even even if they you know a lot more
were professional and a lot more local
but a lot of them were open micros but
even to get them laughing is good
because you know comedians don't really
laugh
this is how comedians laugh
ugh
right like we'll be in the back i
remember being in the back of the
[ __ ] comedy store whatever it is
upstairs at the laugh factory watching
comics
and they do a joke and you're just like
huh oh yeah right mm-hmm
like you're filing papers that you
forgot about oh okay
it's just our business you know and so
we'll watch it and we're just like okay
now
yes he get okay all right so he pulled
one over on me for a quick sec but i get
it now
um
so uh yeah and then i got off stage and
it was great we had a good time
uh
i know i didn't really wanna i didn't
really know if i wanted to go up and
kristen was like you should go up let's
go let's go up and i was like all right
cool we'll [ __ ] do it
so we left calvin at the airbnb dude we
took out an airbnb it's like a [ __ ]
kristin booked an airbnb that was like
severely discounted because it was like
tuesday through wednesday or [ __ ] one
monday tuesday wednesday or some [ __ ]
and it was like so marked down and it
was like this baller ass place with a
hot tub first of all 107 degrees in
austin bro anywhere beside hey
anywhere to the east of phoenix
saunaville
dude
anywhere to the east of phoenix
saunaville take albuquerque anywhere
east of that
sauna i can deal with the heat if it's
dry
dude anywhere east of phoenix
there better be a [ __ ] old asian man
with a towel wrapped around his
midsection too high
walking around with [ __ ] flip-flops
that my buddy in high school would have
worn to soccer practice before he took
the field
otherwise
you're out of your element dude because
you're in a sauna
it's just too hot no matter where the
[ __ ] you are
may on
may on
and i can deal with 150 degrees if it's
dry put the misters out my lips might
crack my anus might get bloody and
instead of [ __ ] air will come out
and go me up
and i won't [ __ ] for as long as i'm in
phoenix
because of the heat keeping it up in my
colon but dude when you step to the
right of phoenix
saunaville dude how do people live
in like
north carolina i'm gonna i want to look
seriously in your face i know you can't
see me but a lot of you are watching i
know i know i can't see you but a lot of
you are watching me on uh on youtube
hey people in north cackalacka
hey just real quick and i want to be
serious people in north kakalaki
what do you do what are you doing dude
it's too it's [ __ ]
you can't breathe man may on
may on
i mean [ __ ] like
it's so dude i was walking around austin
all right i go okay all right
took my shirt off started walking around
on the street dude all right
you're gonna play like that
hey austin you're gonna pretend like
there's not [ __ ]
just beautiful stained oak wood within
like there's not beautiful stained oak
wood within arms reach for me at all
times you're gonna tell me there's not a
[ __ ] fat russian guy with a waist
high white towel
sitting next to some sizzling coals
you're gonna tell me that that's not
true okay shirts come off right outside
of j crow i don't give a [ __ ] dude if
it's gonna be that hot guess what shirts
come off
thank god i wore pants dude i showed up
i flew in i landed i got off the plane i
had sweats on oh boy was that a mistake
dude i got a [ __ ] it's got to be that
that's with that song change clothes and
go that was from when [ __ ] straight
up jay-z one time flew from lax
anywhere to the east of phoenix dude he
goes like this oh [ __ ] i should have had
my shorts on
oh my god i bought sweats and i took and
i touched down anywhere today he's to
phoenix i should have won i should have
worn shorts and no shirt
it's just too hot dude and i don't want
to [ __ ] and moan but it's like
work with me
you're pushing me on over to the west
so it's like i get sick at la i'm here
and i'm like oh we dealt with covet
horribly the homeless is out of control
and holy [ __ ] it's way too woke
and then i fly past phoenix
and i'm just like oh
but my skin
is off the charts with how unlivable
it is here
because what's with
i mean dude it's it's just unbelievable
man i'll take dry heat any day over that
humidity
i i i don't know man
and it's fine too march and like like
people are like chicago best city in the
world have you ever walked around any
time
not in september
best city in the world
best city in the world chicago you've
been to chicago
yup best city in the world
for four days in september
that's what it should be seriously i
swear to god if the tagline was chicago
best city in the world for four days in
september i'd buy [ __ ] real estate
there because at least they're honest
it's either [ __ ]
freezing out or you gotta okay shirts
come off outside of j crew great good
that's how it's gonna be then dude work
with me otherwise my shirt i'm going to
take the [ __ ] off like hulk hogan and
wrestlemania just one arm
why is crystalline got his hand to his
ear he's doing that [ __ ] you know
because it's too hot he's doing that
hulk hogan thing oh okay i get it
there go my dogs barking shut up your
incels
let me calm down
i was out today in los angeles and it
was fine so i was in austin
so hot did two shows one two poppins
mike linochie was like can i promote you
i'm like no i may not do it and he was
just like please and i was like no
you're welcome for just popping in
but don't promote me and it was still
packed out you know because he kept
saying special guest and i was like we
know who it is dude you open for me
special he's like my i'm his best friend
special guest big special guest
so we had a good time i did about 45
minutes that's way too long but whatever
and the thing is i'm coming to austin i
just don't have it yet all right right
now i'm working on other dates i had i
was trying to get the right theater and
it's booked everything's booked for
covid you know because of covet all the
other comedians
and and musicians and even magicians are
out there like trying to get these spots
and
so i will do austin and i will be back
and then we went to dallas dude
and the whole reason why
we went to texas anyway was because this
person
hit me up and said hey will you do a
corporate gig now if you're gonna ask
chris deleo to do a corporate gig the
answer immediately
no why because corporate gigs are
notoriously horrible they're worse than
college gigs okay
because corporate gigs are a bunch of 60
year old men that are just sitting in a
banquet hall somewhere that happens to
be
in a [ __ ] hyatt regency or a radisson
inn and
nine
sixty-year-old men come up and try and
give inspirational speeches about how
they came up in whatever business
has to do with this corporate gig and
it's emotional or it's very bad and then
there's like a life coach and then they
say oh yeah by the way here's a comedian
that you probably don't know about
because we aren't in his demo crystalia
and they give you the microphone and
you're like so
what's the difference between men and
women
you ever go to [ __ ] home depot and
it's like what and these six-year-old
men are like bring on paul ryser though
so it's an eat shit-a-thon
so i wanted to say no but then i'm like
you know what
what is this company i asked what the
company was it's a company called sphere
rocket now obviously that's a fake
company because that's not a real name
but that was the name they went with and
that's and i bought it and whatever and
i said to kristin
hey i'll do this gig if you come with me
and calvin can come i wanna i wanna buy
him a cowboy hat
and she was like i would love to go to
texas so i say it's on [ __ ]
so i said yes they said what are your
stipulations i gave them a bunch of
stipulations and then they said yes and
so i said okay
so i say
prepared this is going to be [ __ ]
awful i say can i bring somebody to
[ __ ] wet the room up for me you know
so mike lenocchi came wet the room up
for me i said he gonna do 10 minutes you
know they had a guy try and stand up for
the first time ever
and then mike linocci and then me so the
guys so we get there and they're like hi
welcome here's the green room the green
room is not a green room the green room
is just a room that [ __ ]
happens to be there and they're like we
have your club soda and i was like oh
that's amazing i actually said i want a
club soda this is hilarious like i don't
even have a ride or people was like
what's in right i'm like i don't know
man what do you think i am kat williams
green m m's and don't look at me
you know i just uh water
and so
if you make
club soda and if you make eye contact
with me more than six seconds i [ __ ] my
pants and you have to clean it up deal
sign on the bottom line so um
so we get there and it looks fine you
know they're talking there's a life
coach talking and then another comedian
that's trying to do stand-up and it's
you know it's going about as well as
you'd think it's the first time you ever
tried doing stand-up but i can't tell
how good the [ __ ] audience is because
this guy's
on stage for the first time ever right
and i don't know i don't know how to
gauge the audience there's about 300
people 400 people there
so i say all right mike
go ahead and try not to do too much
crowd work because
i might have to [ __ ] do it right like
a lot of you guys may not know this but
as a comedian
like
last resort in a
in a corporate gig in a company they
really want you to roast them right so
so i'll that'll be my backup plan
because i want i'm supposed to do 45
[ __ ] minutes
and i can't roast them for 45 [ __ ]
minutes right
so i'm gonna start with material if that
doesn't go well then i'm just gonna have
to roast them so i tell mike
dude two do 10 minutes but don't do too
much crowd work because you might have
to leave that for me i'm going to be out
there
in a sea of people that don't know who
the [ __ ] i am or maybe they do
right but this is the [ __ ] that's going
on through my mind
so mike goes out there and starts
crushing okay he starts doing
some crowd work which is fine and it's
going really well and then he starts
doing his material and he's doing his
like edgy stuff and it's crushing
so i'm like okay good at least they're
gettable but also what if they just like
mike
what if i'm out there he's doing 10
minutes he knows he's doing 10 minutes
he's got the confidence of hey i'm mr 10
minute guy here's my whole
hot load for 10 minutes
and then your boys gotta go up the mr
hollywood oh professional let's see what
you got dude for 45 minutes
so i'm like [ __ ] and now i'm feeling it
and yeah i just did the creek in the
cave and yeah i just did the vulcan
gas company and yeah your boy crushed a
lot but this is a different story and
corporation get corporate gigs
absolutely are you know they're terrible
so i get out there and i'm like i'm
gonna do material i'm gonna get out
there i'm gonna do my material mike wet
up the stage just like he should have
like a professional i'm gonna get out
there and i'm gonna [ __ ] just do my
material and it's gonna be smooth
sailing so i get out there and the first
thing i do is i say hey guys how you
doing hey look at this guy what's up
with this guy boom i'm in crowdwork
already some [ __ ] baby
he immediately succumbs to the pressure
i yes dude
he immediately wants to take him down to
crutchfield ah yes he's insecure
he's going up oh i'm gonna do this this
this got my whole setlist ironed out in
my head goes up and says hey guy
what's your name ah
yes insecurity peeks through the veil
he wanted to crush so soon
he wanted to get to the set so soon
he thought that maybe that he was gonna
get up and do some crowd work and then
he thought that maybe he could ease his
way into some material so soon
he absolutely went up with a plan but
then life smacked him in the face
but he's a professional right
so he's breathing within himself and
he's telling everyone about this new guy
that he's talking about doing crowd work
and he just starts
leveling the place
he just now you know me i don't mince
words but he just
starts
ordering a roof for this place because
this one's getting blown off
now you know i don't mince words i like
to be honest and i like to keep [ __ ]
subtle but he just
starts praying for the third floor
because they're gonna [ __ ] crush
their spines when they fall through the
roof of this banquet hall which happens
to be on the second floor
so i make fun of this and i got a lot
and i noticed mike lenocchio like a
[ __ ] homie is out there getting
it on camera
he's getting a lot of it on camera and
your boy did so i start so now i do 10
minutes of crowd work and then i'm like
let me just test the waters on this
material let me just test the waters
okay
i test the waters
water is freezing cold
i test the water
water's freezing cold
was crushing with the crowd work go back
to some material material
water's freezing cold
so i go okay maybe let me check the
water a little later
get back to some [ __ ]
crowd work
and now i got to start praying for the
people on the third floor again
and i'm not religious i hope i'm doing a
good job but i'm not religious but this
roof's going to give out
do you have hey crowd do you have on
your fire retardant suits
then it's going to be a doozy
so i do 20 minutes more of crowd work
i'm on stage for 30 minutes
i start to dip into some material
water's freezing cold
and i don't bomb up bombing material but
it's just not what they want so i get up
to 45 minutes and i've probably done
four minutes of material
if that
i would say
i did 41
minutes of roasting this audience and
they're loving it okay
and i finally say well guys
it's about time to wrap it up
and the ceo stands up from the back of
the room
and says hey chris
and i say yeah
and he says gotta
he says got a message for you and i go
uh-oh
and his the person who put the show
together walks up slowly to the room and
i'm like what the [ __ ] is happening
she
walks right up to the stage and goes
like this
and i'm like okay i guess she wants the
microphone so i give it to her and she
says the ceo of the company would like
to offer you and then she says a sum of
money
to do
15 extra minutes
would you accept
and i grabbed the microphone and i said
well i guess i'm a hooker today
so i did it
and they put a timer on
for the 15 extra minutes and the timer
counted down boy did i feel like a
[ __ ] hooker
[Music]
but isn't that everyone doing a job you
know you're just doing it for that stack
aren't you um
and it was fun and i got off stage bro
by the way the entrepreneur the guy had
the whole company was hilarious man and
i made fun of it i roasted everybody but
dude there was a company there was a gun
the entre the [ __ ] ceo of the company
was 24 years old and he had a [ __ ]
shirt on that said entrepreneur
alien secretly trying to take over the
world
un it was unbelievable dude so i had
listen i have it
i have
the a lot of this set i don't have all
of this set but i have a lot of it i'm
thinking of uploading it to the more
crystallia channel on youtube
i don't know if i should because it's
from far away or not but if you leave a
comment
and if this gets enough comments under
this video
saying we want to see the crowd work
video for me at this corporation sphere
rocket then i'll think about uploading
it but i gotta you know it's not the
like there's another one i put up on
crystallia uh on the youtube the crowd
work at the in hollywood and that one's
a little better quality but this sounds
good and but it's from far away but i'll
put it up if you guys comment and if
enough comments are on the uh the
youtube because i did it for the last
one like i posted an instagram and i
said if this gets like two thousand or
three thousand uh
comments i'll post the crowd work set
and you did and then i did and it's you
know i think it's got like 300 000 views
on there right now but anyway um
on youtube yeah so just uh
that's what's up so let me know if you
want if you want me to post it because i
i don't know it's a lot of work for me
to [ __ ] it's actually not a lot of
work for me but i got to tell somebody
to do it and then it's a lot of work for
them i went to um uh
but dallas was great and then we left
dallas dude
and
by the way
i don't know about this place because
i'm from have you ever been to buckies
let me google this [ __ ] place
you've been to bucky's
ivan gets rid of says he's been to
bucky's
bucky's convenience store company
so
i don't know
what the deal is
with this bucky's place
but i mean if you look up pictures of
bucky's
okay so we went to bucky's ever since
our inception in 1982 we have been
committed to providing a clean friendly
and in stock experience for our
customers
regardless of where you may find us if
this store is big or small near afar the
mission remains the same let me tell you
something it's big okay it was small i
don't know what even small
this is how it should be regardless of
where you may find us if the store is
big or big as [ __ ]
near or far the mission remains the same
dude i walked in a buck i was like oh
yeah let's piss and we'll get a [ __ ]
you know i told the sprinter bran
sprinter van to pull over
pulled over
went into the buckies
okay
man i don't know if you know about
buckies they're not a lot of people
listen to me in canada or australia or
uk
i've never been a bucky's this was in
the middle of dallas and austin and dude
this is a mecca of convenience store
it's got
first of all i wanted to go in and get
something to eat everything has meat in
it everything has you couldn't get it i
mean here i am mr [ __ ] l.a coming in
i'm like oh yeah i don't really feel
like eating meat because i ate i drank
nine cups of coffee already and i don't
want to have to [ __ ] it out in 30
minutes
and uh and i get into bucky's and it's
literally there is a
it's a convenience store but it's also
got aisles and aisles of beef jerky
different beef jerkys you know what
beef jerky beef jerky connoisseurs
be fine with just the one kind of beef
jerky okay
no he likes it i can get rid of love's
beef jerky dude have three or four kinds
of beef jerky then okay but don't have a
wall this place had a wall of beef jerky
it was like when neo gets
shown into the matrix of the [ __ ] and
all those tvs come up onto the side this
is like
and then [ __ ] you see all those
thousands of tvs those are all beef
jerkys this is like the [ __ ] the
matrix the gopher matrix because bucky's
mascot is a gopher and it was it's it's
so much beef jerky that they just had a
whole section of it and and it's it's
it's for it's all it's so long and i'm
like god damn that's a lot of beef jerky
but you can also get like don't have a
place where you can get beef jerky
and
toothpaste
like just go one place should be for
[ __ ] your mouth up
and then another place you gotta go to
to make your mouth all better
right but you can get anything at this
bro i'm not [ __ ] around you can get
an ottoman at this co at this customers
at this convenience store you can get
like a really nice
frame
it's like it's like
in the middle of bucky's and you know
this if you've been there but in the
middle of bucky's
there is
there is in this conv they got a nerf to
constantly [ __ ] convinced in the
middle of this buckies and every buckies
i suppose because i'm here at the one
i'm looking at in the picture too
there is a
[ __ ]
pork sandwich making station
there is a pork
sandwich
making station
in the middle of this convenience store
there is a pork
sandwich
making
station
and they don't stop
because people are ordinary now that's
the weirdest thing to be in a
convenience store like i swear to god i
would have been less
shocked if in the middle of this
convenience store
there was a beach
dude i couldn't
there's nine people working at this
station just folding up por it's so like
i'll eat pork but like let me just see a
little bit of it
you know
like if the second you see too much pork
i'm like uh
nah that's gross
you know when you just see like like i'm
talking about like 30 animals worth of
pork you're just like
all right well maybe i would have had
one if you just had this behind closed
doors
but it was like a [ __ ]
a wall cascading of like just pork just
dipped in [ __ ] barbecue just just
deadly [ __ ] you know
in the meantime you can buy an ottoman
here
like you walk in you're not even that
hungry you see this poor guy like oh and
i was with [ __ ] kristen and mike's
girlfriend so they walk in and they're
like oh i think maybe oh
you know all that all the chicks got to
see is something that doesn't belong and
they're like now that's interesting
so she gets a pork sandwich mike gets a
pork sandwich and i don't mean to rat
him out but he the [ __ ] buckies is so
big he got the pork sandwich first we
were walking around and he finished it
and i was like what the [ __ ] and then
his girlfriend came on he's like you're
gonna pay for that right and he goes
yeah and she walks away and he's like i
used to do this [ __ ] all the time in
high school i'm not gonna pay for it oh
dude
bucky's thief
so it's so big that like they don't even
have enough it's so big i poured it i
was like where's the coffee and that
some guy just points over there where
the coffee is and you just like pour it
yourself and i'm just like is this [ __ ]
free like i don't even know like where
do i pay for it at the front how do they
know what i have
i just said are you using the honor
system in bucky's
and so i order a turkey sandwich off of
the because there's
you can only get pork and then there's
the station next to it another whole
station with like computer
tvs and you just push what you want
and nothing with no meat like nothing
you get a salad you get a garden salad
and it's like which pork loin would you
like in it
what what body of the p what body part
of the [ __ ] pig would you like in
this salad oh you're like oh yeah can i
get a salad ooh healthy today okay what
part of the pig would you like in it
since you're being healthy we'll ask you
so i got a turkey sandwich
and because here's my mistake because of
how
amazing like
you
whenever i go to a place and i'm like
unless it's a deli right which this is
not it's a convenience store i say
unless it's a deli because deli always
pile of [ __ ] on i say
i want double meat in it because these
con these [ __ ] places [ __ ] out and
they'll give you like two slices really
what you're eating is just bread you're
eating like a [ __ ] just a pocket of
it's just all bread and in the middle
there's like just a little bit of a
[ __ ] chicken in it and it's like i
might as well just eating a [ __ ] loaf
of bread for [ __ ] sake
so it says of course because we're in
texas do you want extra meat and so i
say yeah because i'm like they're not
gonna [ __ ] pull one over on me dude i
got the sandwich
i swear to god dude this [ __ ] thing
it weighed 40 pounds it was like a
[ __ ] picking up a plate on it at the
gym i wanted to slide it on the side of
an olympic bar
like it was unbelievable dude walking
out of this thing
it was so [ __ ] big this meat was so
i'd take one look at it and i just say
it's too much turkey i don't want to see
all of this
so i took two bites and i [ __ ] you
know
that was it
what a [ __ ] i am i just wanted a salad
hey bucky have some greens have some
green [ __ ]
you can buy like stuff like live laugh
[ __ ] love whatever that thing is like
there was one thing you could buy that's
like a wood
art piece of art and it said and it had
a cannon on it and it said come take it
like so texan to not even have a gun on
it like a cannon come take what my
cannon who's got a [ __ ] cannon
the people who shot the buggies
come take it
i kind of part of me wanted to kind of
like grab it and just leave with it and
have them be like hey boy what you doing
i said well i was just following
directions
come come it says come take it i thought
it was free i'm sorry i thought they
were complimentary
um bucky's is insane
and then i left bucky's and some guy
drove by and said crystalia what's up
and i was like oh what's up and then my
brother texted me hey did some guy just
say hi to you and i'm like you're in la
what the [ __ ] going on and he was like
yeah he always writes me i dude i just
[ __ ] like the internet in the world
is so weird right now you know i'm
walking down with 40 pounds of turkey
and mike's girlfriend by the way got
this is what she got um
[ __ ] you can get fudge at bucky's okay
fudge
uh a slushie whatever the [ __ ] like the
7-eleven things
um
cotton candy
uh uh
and
a like a churro or something
and was just walking out and something
pork and i was like are you nine
unbelievable boot dude not booed dude
join our team and grow those bucky's
careers we are looking for dedicated
hard-working individuals to join the
bucky's family give us a holler and come
grow with us
i talked about bucky's way too much oh
look at this [ __ ] [ __ ] are you
kidding me
get
they got car washes dude just be a city
is there a mayor at bucky's hey i walk
into bucky's next time you walk into
bucky's and honestly be like can i talk
to the mayor i guarantee they're like
hold up let me let him get get jack get
get mr
get jack
he's over at the car wash handing out
pamphlets because he's running for a
second term
get jack
he comes in with a [ __ ] pork sandwich
hey how's it going
i'm i'm mayor jack bucky
uh look at this news impress in bucky's
where are they here are the locations
here
if there's any on the west coast
i'd be surprised but maybe there are
alabama florida
georgia
georgia kentucky south carolina texas
all a bunch of texas
wow a lot in texas wow jesus christ
there's like 50 in texas
wow only in yeah see none
hey dog shut up i got [ __ ] too many
dogs
um
let's do some misconnections here before
we get out of here
pasta for you
here here's one pasta for you i made
extra alfredo pasta ladies like to taste
my alfredo sauce
i am clean and vaccinated ub2 wow
i made extra alfredo
i mean you know
let's just you can shorten this down so
so
pasta for you
taste my alfredo sauce i'm clean this
guy really i like when they get extra
with it i made like they're [ __ ]
novelists like they're like they're
writing a book with a [ __ ] guy with a
shirt coming off on the front cover
holding the damsel i made extra alfredo
pasta like dude totally losing the
sexuality and sensuality of it by just
bringing up pasta immediately
hey made pasta
want to eat my [ __ ] gooey alfredo
sauce i'm clean and vaccinated like dude
here's another one delivering wood to
you
get it
sanuendo but getting right to the point
i love how he just says get it
hey i'm doing home delivery if here's
another one the [ __ ] he knows the pie
it's like he knows the pasta guy is this
the pasta guy talking about wood now hey
i'm doing home delivery if you're
needing some good hard wood i can swing
in sun professional swinging i like my
wood to be worked on if you know what i
mean yeah dude dude
you don't
ever need to say
if you know what i mean on craigslist
we know what you mean and it's sexual
hey wanna suck my [ __ ] if you know what
i mean
yeah i cracked the code
i like my wood to be worked on if you
know what i mean if interested hit me up
traveling from inland empire to santa
clarita
okay
here's another one wow i'm looking for
ally
it's a specific texter
um i'm looking for ali
from west palmdale you replied to my ad
two different times about having your
belly button played with saying you were
interested and you sent me some photos
what a weird kink but hey no judging
message me so we could set something up
means
i'm sure he means
vagina
if not
i love kinks that are so like the they
get so far from being sexual that it's
just like is this even sexual yeah let
me play with your belly button what
yeah you want to get together and eat
some sandwiches and watch [ __ ]
bosom buddies
you're like
and if and [ __ ] nah
just sit
you want to sit with some [ __ ]
you want to sit with some [ __ ] travis
barker merch on
and just eat sandwiches while we watch
while we watch home improvement
and [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] ruin it
it's not even sexy at what point is it
sexual
yeah
just got a boner eating a [ __ ] turkey
club
um
game here's another one game night
exclamation point i used to host game
night with a guy in town he moved to the
909 and now i miss playing
he'd just sit back and enjoy me
literally
beating that pants off him okay so
foreign got definitely took a turn
thought it was maybe again this one
thought was maybe just gonna be about
game night couldn't believe how i worked
the joystick okay wow you know these
[ __ ] innuendos get better and better
the game wouldn't end till i got the
prize
i hope this doesn't have a if you know
what i mean in it the game would end and
he would leave complete completed
satisfied completely satisfied that i
had one again exclamation point i love
the exclamation points wow he couldn't
believe how good i was exclamation point
this is amazing so i need to find
another game player no just period which
is great because it's a little bit
sullen right there right
we could play off we would play often
so bring your joystick over for hours of
fun
his was the right size for my game
console i mean dude getting so in the
weeds
sit back and watch me work the joystick
you'll be amazed at how good i am
unbelievable dude
okay we got two more and then we're
gonna bounce
here's another one wondering about the
missed connections five six two it's
come to that stage in my life where i'm
looking around and not recognizing
anything we have all been there but now
it includes myself
i don't
know if we've all been there so far but
anyway so the misconnection is
rediscovering myself
is this what they say is the onset to
midlife crisis
has anyone else been through this before
or find yourself in the same spot
how often do you say this is not what i
think i actually want anymore
edit
this is not a post looking to explore
intimate relationships with another man
sorry it gave you that impression dude
is this a suicide note dude this guy is
so this guy
this is this is the one this is the one
that isn't even an innuendo we found it
this one is so deep in the weeds of
innuendo that he's literally saying by
the way this isn't even an innuendo if
you know what i mean
what is what is it's the first two
sentences that really set things off to
a i don't know what's happening and then
it just keeps
snowballing it's come to the stage in my
life where i'm looking around and not
recognizing anything
does he mean literally like is he old
we have all been there but now it
includes myself
no we have not all been like what do you
mean like looking at a door being like
is this a door
you got to go to a doctor bro stop
posting online
wow
this guy is like the
the
alternative really artists artist of
craigslist
just
deep in the [ __ ]
matrix of innuendos just even edits at
the end this is not a post looking to
explore intimate relationships with
another man sorry i give that impression
this guy is an artist bro
this is where we all strive to be
oh here's two more he needs some milk
and then in the subject i need to go for
a milk run send private pictures wow
here's another one you said you were a
singer santa monica i'm a guy that was
playing my dance music on keyboards you
are a female in shape between 18 and 30.
you said you were a singer and sounded
like
bebe rexha i don't know that is we
decide is that a
we decided to record some material
together and then go on tour and move in
together to myself i mean this guy
doesn't [ __ ]
is this guy is this like a
uh role playing or what the how do you
not have this person's number then we
moved in together we have a son anyway
get in contact with me you're carl's mom
um we go into her together and move to
the center of my class please contact me
if you're serious about your
professional and personal secure future
what the [ __ ] is this guy talking about
yo
miss connect craigslist is getting real
like deep as [ __ ] this is the metaverse
craigslist isn't a metaverse
uh unbelievable i'm out dude
we did it babies
chrissalia.com for tour going to atlanta
going to um
what do you call it
uh
denver colorado going to boston get your
tickets washington d.c
oakland stockton peoria rockford
illinois raleigh savannah cheyenne
denver boston jacksonville hit them up
baby get them good tickets while they
last some of them are almost sold out uh
and then go to get your merch at
crystalia.com don't push me oops we got
the life life rips [ __ ] we got other
bangers coming we got the life rips
tumblers now out which are cool to go
for your [ __ ]
you run your errands with the life rips
drink that ice americano you know it um
but we love you subscribe and also if
you want me to post that video leave a
comment that you want me to post that
video and check out my other podcast
lifeline i do with my brother
uh subscribe to this make friends in the
comments hey guys that was it for
youtube if you want to watch the rest of
the episode the uncut episode go to
patreon.comcrystalia and you can get the
uncut episodes of patriot of uh of these
of these youtube videos and uh watch
them all uncut from here on out and also
the previous ones there's also an extra
episode a month that you can uh be
privy to when you do join our patreon
and there's like 13 of them now so you
can go uh sign up today and binge watch
them right now uh every month we do one
and then also there's behind the scenes
footage there's another segment we do
called review mode and there's a lot of
other stuff there's a discord we chat on
uh but uh sign up patreon.com
thanks guys
[Music]
you